hola buenas noches pues el presidente
tiene todos sus recursos básicamente lo
que hemos visto hasta el día de hoy como
su equipo de campaña ha colocado varias
demandas para detener el conteo de votos
pero como ocurrió en pensilvania se
realizó digamos la primera audiencia
para disputar estos 93 votos esto
tendría que hacer el presidente
básicamente colocar una demanda en
tribunales estatales o federales por
pequeñas cantidades de votos lo cual
sería digamos un esfuerzo muy grande por
parte de su campaña pero también como lo
ha dicho el presidente podría utilizar
la estrategia de decir que hay un fraude
electoral pero desde el punto de vista
jurídico es más fácil probar porque se
requieren pruebas y evidencias muy
específicas de que fue así y hasta el
momento no se han dado digamos indicios
de que esto fuera el caso diana que
resalta del discurso de joe biden que
son que dio hace unas horas o no
presidencial
bueno uno de los aspectos más
importantes es que el candidato
demócrata dice que la democracia es
difícil y que por lo tanto a veces hay
que esperar y tener paciencia y es que
su campaña ha sido muy cauta al esperar
el conteo de cada voto y esto lo que
muestra es que solamente el candidato
demócrata hablara de un discurso de
victoria así es el caso en un futuro
cuando se tenga la certeza plena del
conteo final de estos votos sobre todo
porque en estados como georgia como
nevada ya los secretarios estatales han
dicho que incluso el conteo podría
finalizar dentro de diez días se espera
pues que esta noche continúen llegando
más resultados de estados como arizona
pero realmente debido a la pandemia ya
que muchas de estas boletas electorales
enviaron a último minuto y cada estado
tiene sus reglas para recibir estas y
contarlas pues básicamente ese es el el
discurso que llama la atención y aparte
de cómo va a bailén a llevando hasta el
momento hasta el momento de esta noche
si bien gran ventaja sobre trompo es que
está siendo cauto
en la manera en cómo se comunica con los
estadounidenses